je veux redire ici notre émotion à la
démission du maire actuel Yannick Morez
après une violente agression et je lui
redis toute notre solidarité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sans prendre à un élu quel que soit son
mandat quel que soit son étiquette c'est
sans prendre à la République
Yannick Morel a été victime de la
vindique du harcèlement des
intimidations de groupuscules d'extrême
droite et la semaine dernière son
domicile a été incendié le gouvernement
est à ses côtés et je sais que la très
grande majorité d'entre vous le soutien
[Musique]
est un
le groupe démocrate est choqué que
certains soient restés assis nous sommes
scandalisés
le vent nous
aujourd'hui
les extrêmes sortent de l'ombre des
complexés espérant que la République se
meurt et que leur violence est une
solution ce maire a démissionné parce
qu'il était agressé par l'extrême droite
et abandonné par l'État face à elle
c'est-à-dire par vous le sous-préfet de
Saint-Nazaire a-t-il vraiment refusé une
protection rapprochée à ce maire comme
les cris Mediapart pourquoi le préfet de
Loire-Atlantique n'a-t-il pas interdit
la manifestation du 29 avril laissant
l'extrême droite parader jusque sur les
marges de la mairie de Saint-Brévin
est-ce monsieur Darmanin qui a donné ses
instructions complaisantes avec
l'extrême droite lui qui trouve Madame
Le Pen trop molle que l'émotion soit
partagée c'est une chose
qu'on évite les récupération s'en est
une autre
j'ai été maire comme Gérald Darmanin
comme d'autres ici les menaces les
insultes les outrages les fake news sur
les réseaux sociaux les mises en cause
les invectives elles viennent de partout
quand vous êtes meilleurs elles viennent
de l'extrême droite elles viennent aussi
de l'extrême gauche la vérité c'est que
défendre les mers c'est préserver la
démocratie ça n'est pas seulement monté
en épingle un fait divers tragique
scandaleux ou l'extrême droite est en
cause dans l'espèce c'est assumer dans
tous les cas de dénoncer les scandales
et c'est éviter d'appeler à la
protection policière quand Jean-Luc
Mélenchon explique que la police elle ne
protège pas mais qu'elle tue c'est ça
aussi c'est ça aussi la continuité alors
au milieu de tout ça au milieu de tout
ça soyez cohérent
combattant toutes les violences d'où
elles viennent avec la même force et
avec la même virulence mais là on fera
un utile pour la République et pour la
démocratie